before the Gaza ceasefire took hold
early Friday driving along this road was
dangerous the whole stretch of the 120
km border between Lebanon and Israel was
a war zone Israel and the Lebanese armed
group Hezbollah have so far held fire
during the 4-day Gaza
ceasefire some of the tens of thousands
of Lebanese who left their Villages have
come back to check on their homes and
those who stayed behind
Israel didn't achieve anything what did
it hit stones and people we have
experienced this many times they can
never break our
will 7 weeks of crossborder exchange of
fire was intense 14 civilians were
killed including journalists who were
believed to have been directly targeted
the Israeli Army says during the 4day
ceasefire it will continue preparations
for the next phase of its war on all
fronts hasb is likely to be doing the
same it has said Southern Lebanon will
remain what it calls a support front for
Hamas as long as Israel's attacks
against Gaza
continue Hezbollah has enjoined the
battle in full force calibrating attacks
to keep it largely contained to the
Border but it says that could change
depending on Israel's actions in Gaza
and in
Lebanon Israel's intentions are
aggressive it's the country that kills
and takes land it does this under the
command of the United States the United
Nations peacekeeping force in southern
Lebanon which has been powerless in
stopping the violence is calling on both
sides to avoid further escalation
warning of even what it calls more
devastating consequences zanah aljazera
Southern
Lebanon make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer